salut tous les attend c'est quoi ce truc
tant elle est dégueulasse l'image là
c'est pas possible je te parie que je
peux régler ça en un claquement de
doigts tu veux voir à temps 1 2 voilà
c'est quand même beaucoup mieux et en
plus je vous montre comment on fait
juste après l'intro et ses amis les gens
on se retrouve pour un nouveau tuto pour
améliorer vous en vidéo et comme
d'habitude pour voir l'astuce
d'aujourd'hui on va se servir d'une
vidéo qui est déjà sur la chaîne
publique là pour la voir juste la tuque
lit et au mieux on va parler d'un truc
vraiment important que dis-je
indispensable quand on veut appliquer
des effets assez vidéo alors la plupart
du temps dans final que les gens quand
ils veulent appliquer un effet à leurs
vidéos bas ils font comme ça on peut en
effet on fait glisser déposer sur le
rush est terminée et ben en fait il ya
un truc vachement plus simple est
vachement le plus pratique à faire si on
veut pas se prendre la tête pour les
effets et ouais parce que pour gagner du
temps en fait on va pouvoir utiliser ce
qu'on appelle un aggiornamento ailleurs
c'est un calque en gros mais ça fait
toujours bien de se la péter avec
l'accent anglais et se dispose d'amples
logiciel de montage nativement mais
bizarrement pas surfer anelka qui doit
elle va falloir télécharger un plugin
mais il est gratuit donc scellé cool ça
va vraiment vous coûter vous mettez pas
en colère ça va aller là bien se passer
ou va bien se passer
alors je vais pas vous faire un tuto sur
comment l'installer puisque le mec qui
propose sans téléchargement afin tuto
qui est super bien fait je vous mets
juste le lien dans la description c'est
en anglais mais il ya les captures
d'écran c'est super facile vous allez
voir c'est fait en 30 secondes grand
maximum non moi ce que je vais faire
c'est surtout vous montrer comment on
l'utilisé et surtout pourquoi c'est le
pied à utiliser que ça va me faire
gagner un temps monstrueux alors une
fois la jungle installé je le retrouve
dans les titres juste là alors on va
travailler sur ce plan je vais vous
montrer comment j'ai travaillé l'image
sur le court métrage on va prendre notre
juste player et venir le déposer juste
au dessus du rush rue des roches qu'on
va vouloir traiter si vous allez voir on
va pouvoir entre été plusieurs à la fois
et là ça fait absolument rien pour le
moment c'est normal complètement
sauf que maintenant au lieu d'appliquer
les effets sur les roches un par un on
va appliquer nos effets directement sur
le calque et puis c'est pas plus
compliqué que ça c'est à dire qu'en plus
on va pouvoir ajuster la longueur du
calq exactement comme ça pour qui
s'applique à l'intégralité de la vidéo
qu'on va traiter alors vous allez me
dire oui bon bah au lieu de faire
glisser sur le rush on va le faire
glisser sur le calque oui il ya quand
même plein davantage à utiliser la jon
cryer déjà on va faire un réglage pour
l'intégralité des plantes de notre vidéo
et ça c'est pas négligeable en terme de
temps en plus de ça ça évite certains
problèmes notamment les little boxes et
le recadrage par exemple si j'applique
ma laideur box directement sur mon plan
est que je fais du recadrage par la
suite et bien vous pouvez voir que la
letter boxe ça devienne complètement le
bordel et qu'à gérer ça va être très
compliqué alors que si je met
directement en effet l'auteur boxe dans
le calque bas après je peu recadré
mont-blanc exactement comme je veux et
le lecteur box ne va absolument pas
bouger un autre truc cool là dessus
c'est que admettons que vous avez
travaillé la couleur sur un rush et puis
vous l'avez copier après surtout les
autruches puis finalement vous vous
rendez compte que il ya un petit
ajustement à faire sur sur la couleur
sur l'exposition est donc vous le faites
sur un des plans de primes à ses cadres
voire supprimer tous les effets de tous
les autres plans recopier les effets du
plan que vous avez retravailler il
recoller par la suite surtout les autres
mais ça c'est juste chiant
alors qu'avec le calque si vous avez une
modification à faire elle va s'appliquer
sur l'ensemble des plans il y aura rien
a touché ça sera fait directement sur le
calque donc à pas grand chose de plus à
dire si ce n'est que utiliser la just
nucléaire c'est juste indispensable
quand on veut vraiment gagner du temps
quand on fait pas mal de vidéos qui ont
fait le pari une fois que vous aurez
essayé vous pourrez plus vous en passer
voilà les amis c'est tout pour le tuto
d'aujourd'hui si cette vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à mettre un coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air juste en
dessous de cette vidéo si ce n'est pas
déjà fait n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
pour avoir pleins d'astuces pour faire
des super vidéo et en attendant à rester
curieux et moi je vous dis à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
oui j'ai encore changer de décor parce
que parce que voilà je m'ennuie vite
dans un décor là je les aime bien
celui-là d'ailleurs pour me dire dans
les commentaires le décor que vous
préférez de tout ce que j'ai utilisée si
vous préférez assis sur le bureau si
vous préférez la si vous préférez je
sais pas moi